- J'aime chanter et faire
le fou. J'ai envie de faire rir,
si j'ai une mission, c'est ca.
- À travers la chanson,
l'imitation ou les blagues,trtrt
le public. Tout jeune, il imite
le chansonnier Felix Leclerc.
À 12 ans, il passe un concoursbt
en 1955, en formant les Jérolas
avec Jérôme Lemay,
qu'il lance sa carrière.
- ♪ Car la seule chose qui
compte vraiment maintenant ♪
♪ C'est de pouvoir posséderrgrg♪
- Ils écrivent et composent
leurs chansons et en
enregistrent de très nombreusurn
font un duo très populaire
Québec et ailleurs. Ils passent
à la télévision américaau "Ed S.
♪ ♪ ♪
à deux reprises sur la scène
de l'Olympia.
(applaudissements)
Tout ce ss, cette vie de
tournée a un prix. Jean Lapointe
a un pro
et sa carrière en souffre.
- Quaiaiaiai commencé à faire
du cabaret, j'ai commencé
je suis devenu un êtreaiaiaiaim,
cruel et irresponsable.
les Jérolas se séparent.Il fautn
Lapointe est de plus en plus
- Une fois, par exemple, que
je suis entré dans la cellule...
- Au cinéma, il joue
"L'eau chaude, l'eau frette",
dans "J.A. Martin photographe",
entre autres.
- Et à la télévision,
il incarne le rôle-titre
dans la série "Duplessis".
qui écrivent leurs mémoires,
c'est les ratés. S'ils font ça,
s'ils les écrivent, c'estrrrrrrr
ça à Lapalme! Ha! ha!
- Sur scène, il entreprend
une carrière solo et renouegigie
une vingtaine d'albums, dont le
célèbre "Chante-la ta chanson".
- ♪ Chante-la ta chanson ♪vavav♪
- Invité par Raymond Devos
au théâtre Bobino, il triomphe
à Paris. Mais il n'a pas oublié.
En 1982, il fonde la maison
Jean-Lapointe, qui offre
des thérapies aux alcooliques.ln
au Sénat canadien, en 20
combattre une autre dépendance :
il s'attaque à la dedededededed.
la marijuana s'apprête à être
légalisée, il prône une
intervention auprès des jeunesSs
au niveau de la prévention,
sasasasasasa retraite du Sénat,
il remonte sur scène à 76 ans
débuts, Jérôme Lemay, qui mourra
avant la fin de la tournée.
- ♪ Touche pas à Méo Penché ♪- e
carrière, Jean Lapointe a reçu
et Ottawa, et autant dans le
milieu du cinéma et de l'humour
que dans celui de la musique.
mes chansons ♪- - - - - - - - -,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.
- ♪ Mes imitations, m